il ya des inégalités qui sont totalement
incompréhensibles et parfaitement
insupportable entre universités quand on
calcule la dotation d'une université par
étudiant il ya certaines universités qui
ont deux fois plus de moyens que
d'autres
qu'est ce qui justifie sa rien
absolument rien à ce point là c'est pas
possible
en même temps les universités
effectivement continue malgré tout est
la mienne pardon d'en parler mais c'est
ce que je connais le mieux
on est quand même un bon exemple tout en
étant très mal doté avec un grand manque
de moyens arrivent à faire de son mieux
pour que les étudiants soient le mieux
accueilli possible mieux formés possible
y compris parce que les personnels sont
très dévoués à leur tâche qu'ils vivent
presque comme une mission
et ça c'est une très bonne chose d'une
certaine façon même si ça les amène
souvent à compenser de façon abusive le
manque de moyens au travail en deux fois
trop ou en bricolant des choses qu'ils
ne devraient pas bricoler donc bien sûr
il ya ça il ya aussi le fait que enfin
dans ce que j'entends on a parfois
l'impression que finalement la formation
initiale du que c'est ça qu'il s'agit
aurait pour finalité principale voire
pour finalité unique en gros l'insertion
professionnelle et économique mais c'est
pas seulement ça l'éducation
je pense qu'il faut pas qu'on abandonne
ce projet ancien qui date de la sortie
de la seconde guerre mondiale de données
la plus la plus large éducation possible
à la plus grande partie possible de la
population et que donc c'est bien
d'accueillir le plus grand nombre de
jeunes possible à l'université pas
uniquement pour leur donner un travail
derrière
mais aussi pour leur donner l'éducation
la plus développée la plus complète
possible et je crois que je suis
d'accord on a un peu tendance à trop
abandonnée cette mission là et a renoncé
à ne plus assez se battre je suis
d'accord de ce point de vue est ce que
disait françois dubé on laisse trop
faire on n'est pas assez revendicatif on
n'est pas assez combatif
on accepte trop de se soumettre à la
réorganisation de l'université qui finit
par ne plus être ce qu'elle devrait être
et il ya là il y aura un vrai combat à
mener y compris en termes de répartition
des richesses à travers l'ensemble du
site
m éducatif
[Musique]